hello and welcome to the shiki science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about
cert 1 acetoin and how it gets
downregulated
by autophagy in senescent cells and
during aging
and so what i present in this video
mostly stems from this recent nature
cell biology paper
cert 1 is down regulated by autophagy
internescence and aging
so in this video i'll begin by giving a
bit of background to the different
topics involved
and then we'll look at some of the
results from the study and then i'll
give some kind of
outcome and conclusion to take from
these results and kind of
further questions that this research
raises
and there's quite a few so yeah
hopefully this will be an interesting
video
so let's get going then so the best
place to start is with cert one
what is cert one well cert one is
one protein of a family of proteins
known as said two ins
or certains depending on what you want
to say i think it is sirtoens
and cyatoine says something i maybe said
that i made up
you know what i don't think i really
know but it also doesn't really matter
anyway certains are a family of nad plus
dependent diacetylasers
and so what this means is that they use
nad plus as a cofactor to remove
acetyl groups from different proteins
addition or removal of acetyl groups
from proteins
can alter the protein's function and so
certains
can have important roles in a variety of
different biological activities
depending on the proteins that they
decetylate
in the case of cert-1 it mainly
functions through
decisilation of histone substrates and
so histones are proteins that
have dna wrapped around them and compact
into
the form known as chromatin within your
nucleus so by removing acetyl groups
from these testing proteins it can alter
how the dna
is compacted within a nucleus and this
can have a variety of impacts within a
cell
moreover certain one is also known to
deity my favorite protein
p53 and so by de-acetylating a variety
of different proteins
cert one can impinge on the different
nutrient signaling pathways within a
cell
and ix activity is thought to promote
stress resistance
and prevents aging and this is further
supported by the fact that
the levels of nad plus the k factor that
set one depends on
decreases during aging and potentially
contributes
to an age-related reduction in overall
saturated activity
and so activating sertoins by using
compounds such as resveratrol or by
increasing the levels of nad plus
by using nazplus precursors are being
currently
highly researched to try and treat
different age-related conditions
but what's the point of trying to
activate a protein if that protein
isn't even present and so the reason
that i say this
is because the authors of this current
paper previously reported
that the levels of the cert one
equivalent found in yeast
set satu declines following replicative
aging
which is a cause of yeast aging however
the mechanism
as to why this decline was observed and
what happens in humans
hasn't yet been fully addressed and so
that's what the authors of this paper
tried to examine in this latest
publication
so first off they tried to see how the
protein levels of sat-1 changes
during the development of cellular
senescence so why is cellulose in
essence
well cellulosin essence is one of the
hallmarks of aging
with the number of senescent cells
increasing with age
and so senescent cells are cells that
have entered a state of cell cycle
arrest
and this can be induced by a variety of
different upstream stressors within a
cell
interestingly overexpression of sart1
has already been shown
to delay senescence in a human cell line
so what actually happens to sat1 in a
senescent cell
so if we take a look at this first
figure which can only be described as a
beautiful set of western blots
they are very nice we can see that in
different types of senescence induction
there's a decline in cert 1 protein
level and
this can be seen here in terms of
population doubling
so this is just continual passaging of a
cell line
until it stops growing and as you can
see the saturn levels decline during
this time period
we can also see it decline in oncogene
induced senescence
and we can also see it in dna damage
induced senescence
and so the two important things to take
from this is firstly that the cert-1
decline occurs at the protein level
not at the mrna level and so this
suggests that the protein is being
degraded
secondly this decline in cert one was
not seen
in quiescence and so what was causing
set one to get degraded
well one way that proteins can get
degraded within a cell
is via the proteosome however when the
authors inhibited the proteosome in
these cells
it didn't prevent the decline in cert-1
levels
instead it was found that cert-1 protein
decline was dependent
on autophagy now explaining autophagy
probably deserves a video of its own but
i'll do my best to explain it briefly
here
effectively autophagy derives from the
ancient greek
meaning self devouring which reflects
this natural process within a cell
whereby it removes unnecessary or
dysfunctional components
so far there are three different forms
of autophagy
the best understood is macroautophagy
which is more simply just referred to as
autophagy
and what happens in macroautophagy is
different
cytoplasmic components such as proteins
can get encapsulated within vesicles
known as autophagosomes
and these can then fuse with an
organelle within a cell known as the
lysosome
where the components can then get
degraded and eventually recycled
but this is where it gets interesting
because as i've just mentioned
autophagy removes cytoplasmic components
however cert-1 is often found within a
nucleus where it can deacetylate
these histamine proteins and p53 however
if you look at cert-1 localization
within a cell
as you can see in this figure here you
can see that
in the senescent cells you can see these
small little
functor whereby cert one is actually
localizing to the cytoplasm
and summarizing a lot of the data in a
very short way
what was shown was that the way cert one
goes from the nucleus into the cytoplasm
and enters autophagic degradation is by
interacting with one of the components
of the autophagy
machinery lc3 and so this is interesting
because
autophagy is commonly thought to only be
involved in degrading
cytoplasmic components but cert one
isn't alone because this lab had
previously shown that another protein
that declines during senescence
lamin b1 is also degraded via an
lc3 dependent nuclear lysosomal
transport
system and so based on the data it seems
that
this lc3 dependent autophagy degradation
is enhanced during senescence because
the interaction between
cert 1 and lc3 increases but the precise
mechanism as to why this happens
is not so clear but besides looking at
senescence the authors also looked at
cert 1 protein levels
during aging and the way they did this
was by dissecting different organs and
tissues
from young and naturally aged mice what
they saw was that the spleens testes and
thymus of the older mice
showed reduced levels of cert one
protein compared with the younger mice
but it was interesting to note that cert
one protein decline wasn't observed in
all tissues for example the heart liver
kidneys pancreas uterus lungs and muscle
didn't show a decline
and like with the human cell lines in
the mouse tissue
by inhibiting autophagy the levels of
sat 1 could also be rescued
so to bring all this information
together this study shows that
autophagy contributes to the
down-regulation of cert-1 protein
during cellular senescence and during
aging of several mouse tissues and cells
so what can we take from this study well
firstly
it adds support to nuclear substrates
also being targets of the autophagy
pathway
but more on from that it also
potentially provides
a new target in the treatment of
reducing the severity of senescence
for example if the degradation of cert
one could be inhibited
it may delay senescent onset and then
this may
synergize with sat1 activators such as
resveratrol
because in at least one of the figures
in this paper resveratrol wasn't able to
prevent the degradation of cert one
however other studies show
that it can activate set one activity
and so by preventing degradation and
activating the activity of that one
you can see how it could have a
combinatorial impact
but this actually raises another
question why would a senescent cell want
to get rid of cert one
and so i'm going to speculate a little
which is something i don't tend to do
too much on this channel because i like
to base my opinions on facts
but anyway during senescence there are
lots of changes that occur within the
nucleus
and a lot of that's due to the chromatin
rearranging
and cert one decelerates histones
proteins which are really
important in this process and also it's
dc's latest p53 if i forgot to mention
that earlier
and so by degrading sart1 and removing
it from the nucleus
it may help in this reorganization of
chromatin within the nucleus
to establish senescence which is
interesting and cool and i guess
would be interesting to follow up in
further research
and more on from that it'd be very
important to try and work out
what other proteins besides that one and
lamin b1
that seem to get targeted by this
autophagy
mediated degradation especially if ways
of inhibiting this process
is going to be sought after because it'd
be good to examine if there's going to
be any
negative consequences and also just
whilst i was making this video i was
thinking about how
the cert 1 regulation could be impacting
on the circadian rhythm because i
mentioned in a previous video how cert
one activity was necessary for
increasing one of the components
female 1 and its binding on dna and
yeah this pretty much is kind of opening
pandora's box i don't really know how
the circadian rhythm gets impacted in
semesters
and so yeah i think that's in the whole
area in itself
that was worth investigation but that
one is obviously important in this
process
and what was important in lots of
processes so if you can take anything
away from this video you should take
away that
anyway as we've come to the end i hope
you have learned something on this video
and as always thanks for listening